welcome to this video playing empathy
from the US and I wanted to do something
else like c-45 I always play this b6
line which is quite okay but check I
want something check else for a change
playing this system with e five and six
ok we have a closed position now maybe I
should have taken now should have taken
on one deform does this is a bit this is
a bit borrowing this position but ok I
can take and play d5 to open it up well
maybe it might be might be interesting
because I win so many tempe with 96 and
stuff i know it's an isolated pawn but
gum I'm quick with my my development is
quite good and he's got b3 plate so it
shouldn't be a huge problem anyway so
here in rook c8 could be eight I should
have enough activity in this position ok
so here so that 94 is not even playable
because the c3 night hangs it's really
important that white has played b3 the
position would be a much easier for him
to play if he would have had if he would
have um the porn on be too ok so i could
just double double on the C file maybe
that's not bad
okay intend to find the pressure on this
c3 night and not like I'm going to win
it or anything but to make sure you
cannot easily play 94 1 improve his
position in some other way
yeah it's not them it's not especially
great for black but seems fairly handy
solid
I'm wondering this year actually going
see actually threatening to take it 95mm
maybe job maybe is 195 i take d to first
yeah if possible I really assured them
yes but I thought if you what about d4
isn't d4k here t4 night x e6 maybe but
I'm pretty active having don't think I
should be in terrible shape t4 takes
unfortunately i don't have an
intermediate moves like dc-3 what which
is a bit of a shame Bishop g4 I can
consider actually
it's not not on okay let's let's do that
maybe he can take on c6 it's a bit
awkward the smooth but may be possible I
mean I cannot take on c3 okay didn't do
that here yeah I just need to recapture
and if he takes yeah now the question is
Knight takes or route takes I wanted to
play Knight takes two to have this
active night I know the c6 porn looks
really ugly but I am really active in
this position so I'm yeah Brooks III is
this on Roxy three books in sequence III
Quincy 392 checking of one night XD 3
takes on dat hmm ok take stakes naughty
to checking it to look the one checking
e to unfortunately not working this is
all not working because the eight hangs
yeah okay I can just play five if
everything else fails why do I or play a
booth to protect here 94 may be okay I
just 25 ah yeah I'm terribly my
decision-making process is relatively
slow at the moment what this does it I
think it threatens to play um possibly
rook c8
trying to dislodge the snide and maybe
get some 92 Roxy 192 type of
combinations going this can easily
happen yeah it's very tricky disposition
when I don't know that somehow I feel
like he has something in this here and I
don't see it I don't see it but it feels
like there should be should be something
yeah what he doesn't spend lots of time
oh that's remarkable
now he say so not disconnected why am i
missing something blatantly obvious and
he does not really believe his luck or
anything I don't I don't see it really
okay yeah that that is really a bit of a
shaky looking move really it is but I
don't see don't see a direct refutation
or any reputation and actually time
morning they can take it as a very meek
humble I can take here yeah it looks
dangerous to do it looks like a
dangerous thing to do the gunite reform
maybe for Queen d2 I have very little
time left
yeah I wanted to take with the rook but
I don't know if this is helpful rook c8
shape probably this isn't isn't in
playable ten seconds I'm unbelievably
slow the heck am I doing here yeah i
mean i'm giving up the game away just
just about just because of my terribly
slow play I can play rook c8 all the
time and wind doesn't do it black for
fits on time there what the heck did i
do here I mean I'm just I'm just falling
asleep or what I am not completely
idiotic I mean yeah there's simply
nothing going on I mean black black is
actually a good year I can take a 2 but
I have to just I'm just freezing here or
spending I must be I don't know what am
I doing here just spending ages i mean i
can take which which is winning
according to the comp but it feels
somewhat i cannot take f at all because
of f2 yeah okay well it said it was
clear that almost clear that there was
something because this looks so
unnatural but ya hear the problem was I
wanted to take like that but this is
jack is simply not check not playable
and GM yeah i'm i'm i'm worse but check
check
yeah and here I'm just losing time was
somehow his his his long thing irritated
me to no end he spent almost two minutes
on 92 and after that I was falling as
didn't know I'm a hit on the clock and
it took me 30 seconds to play energy
form that's just terrible I mean I
originally wanted to take but i thought
this this is jess is too tricky we have
computer loves YT i am and this was the
right judgment this i was seeing and
thought okay better not but they cannot
spend 30 seconds yeah this is justice
justice just insane very very I know
sometimes it's time for us you had the
examination what the heck was our
thinking yeah alright a bit of a stupid
game I must admit thanks for watching
anyway